don't be rude are you kidding me we can
all quit and go home because the
internet has peaked and it'll never get
better than this hurt you don't do that
oh my god
so what is it exactly good question it's
the Jonas Brothers doing their best
impersonation of the Kardashians circle
like 2008 and update Kim loved it really
confused let's rewind shall we - season
2 of Keeping Up with the Kardashians
you know the episode where Kimberly gets
a Bentley her sisters Kourtney and Khloe
mock her for being a brat and all hell
breaks loose don't do that oh my god
okay now fast forward to present day
we're Joe Jonas decided to bless the
Internet by posting this award-winning a
reenactment of that scene co-starring
his brothers Nick and Kevin to Instagram
you don't do that oh my god can someone
give them the Oscar okay so maybe not
the Oscar but let's at least give them a
round of applause naturally Joe
captioned the clip don't be rude
don't be rude okay but wait my favorite
part though is when Kevin crosses the
screen dead and you know who else is
dead over it Kim Kardashian herself it's
amazing
the reality star hit up the comments
writing oh my god she also shared the
video on Twitter writing alongside it I
love you guys Chloe also weighed in on
Instagram commenting on Joe's post
nailed it I mean but they really did
nail it don't be rude are you kidding
hurt you don't do that oh my god of
course this isn't the only reason fans
are talking about the Jonas Brothers
earlier in the day the group released
the cover art for their upcoming single
what a man gotta do which is set to drop
on Friday the trek is just the latest in
the Joe Broz comeback which launched
last year after a year's long hiatus
from performing together fool you the
trio dropped happiness begins their
first album together in nearly a decade
in 2019 and NBD launched a world tour is
it different when you look also around
on the stage and you see your brothers
and it's not somebody else but it's like
a family changes everything
and I think you know that this started
at a place where it wasn't about okay
let's get right back on tour let's get
right back in the studio it was about
saying okay are we good as family first
and making that the priority and you
know after about a year and a half of
doing some real work on that and having
those tough conversations we got to a
point where we actually said okay we can
do this again and and have it be better
than the way when last time then it's
really special
who's day just got better I mean let's
roll the tape one more time hurt you
don't do that oh my god and on that note
make sure to keep it locked on et for
all the precious Jonas Brothers moments
like this one until next time I'm Hallie
Stephens and remember don't be [ __ ]
rude
[Music]